[Music]
I just joined a sales team as a data
analyst and my first assignment is to
create a sales time series forecasting
model to help predict product sales
before I do that I want to get familiar
with some of the sales data that's
available I'm going to use duet AI to
help me do that since I'm new and duet
AI is trained on Google Cloud specific
data and best practices I'll start in
bigquery Studio a unified collaborative
workspace that helps accelerate data to
AI workflows in the cloud console the
first thing I'll do is create a data set
which I'll use to create a model
later then I want to double check that
the doet AI features I want to use are
enabled here in the upper right of the
screen I can click on the do it AI icon
in the toolbar and make sure that autoc
completion Auto generation and
explanation are all
checked anytime I want to prompt do it
AI through the chat I click this do it
AI icon in the console toolbar and the
chat will open up on the right one of
the things that du AI can help with is
knowing what data I can access for
analysis and how to analyze that
data in order to familiarize myself with
the sales data that's available to me on
this new team I'm going to use duet AI
to explore a bit so I'm going to prompt
it with something like how do I learn
which data set and tables are available
to me in
bigquery okay so it's telling me that
there are a few different ways that I
can learn which data sets and tables are
available to me I want to do this in the
console so I'll ask a follow-up question
how can I do this in the console and I
get my answer with step-by-step
instructions so to do this I'll go to
the Explorer Pane and click add and I
can select public data sets which is
down
here and I can see there are a variety
of public data sets that I can choose
from but I know there's a data set that
my team has been using so I'm going to
look it
up here it
is and I can see some information about
the data set here but I'll go ahead and
view the data set on the left I can see
the tables that are in the data set and
if I click on one of these tables I can
see the schema the data type and if I
click preview I can see a preview of the
data that's in there which is really
helpful for me to look up and see what
kind of data I'll be working
with now I'll hop back into Bakery
studio and now that I know what data is
available to me I can ask a follow-up
question like how can I load different
types of data into big query for use via
the
console and uh duet AI will tell me how
I can do that so this is a small example
of the things that I can ask do at AI
for help with in relation to my data but
I could also ask something like how do I
get started with bigquery at the most
basic level up to something more complex
like how do I create a Time series
forecasting model in bigquery which will
actually be getting help with in a bit
the best part of this is that I don't
have to leave the console to look up how
to do these things I just as do at Ai
and it can tell me now I want to dig in
a bit to some of the queries that I know
are available a to me there's a query
that my team uses that I can see right
off the bat tells me which tables are
being queried from the data set but it
has some additional sections that would
take me some more time to fully
understand so I'll ask duet to help me
with that I'll highlight the query and
click the tool tip to the left here that
says explain this query the response
lets me know the intent of the query is
to find the top 10 users by average sale
price with additional info about how the
the code is structured to get me that
end result so here I can compare the
response from duet AI with the query and
understand how that query is working and
what it's meant to
do then if I run the query I can see
that in fact it does give me the top 10
users by average sales
price this saved me probably 3 to 5
minutes of looking at the query to
understand what it was doing this is a
relatively simple query but I can
already see how helpful and time-saving
this will be for me when I'm looking
through queries that have 30 plus lines
okay next I want to get a bit deeper
into the data and instead of just
knowing the top 10 customers I want to
know what are the total sales for each
product on each
day I'm able to do that right in the
editor so I'm going to close out the
chat and the Explorer pane for now and I
can promp to in the editor to generate a
query for me by starting my my prompt
with the pound sign and writing my
prompt something along the lines of
Select sum of sales by date and products
Casta today from this order items table
joined with products and hit
enter doet AI suggest a query and it'll
actually give me multiple options that I
can tab through I like the first one the
best so I'll hit tab on my keyboard to
accept it and there it is I am going to
modify it a bit because I know that
created at is the table I want to use
for the date and I'll put it in a
descending
order and now I can run the query and
get the
results and I can see here the total
sales for each product for each day
which can be useful to identify trends
like which products are selling best on
which
days okay so I've used duet AI to
explain queries and help me generate
queries to help better understand the
data I'm working with now I can focus on
actually building a forecasting model so
I can help predict sales for my team I
have this query that a teammate shared
with me from their saved queries and
it's going to help me create a Time
series forecasting model before I run it
I'm going to ask duet AI to quickly
explain this query to me it tells me the
intent is to create a Time series
forecasting model using the ARA plus
algorithm and the data that the model
will be trained on as well as the data
set the model would be created in with
which is good to confirm that it's the
data set I created in the
beginning so again I can thank duet AI
for quickly catching me up on that query
versus having to do it myself or ask my
teammate to explain it now I'll run this
query and while that's running I'm
actually wondering what is an ARA plus
model type what does that mean I've
never heard that before so I'll prompt
to at in the chat what is an ARA plus
model type what functionalities does
does it have so it's a model type for
time series forecasting which is good
it's the most computationally expensive
but also provides the most accurate
results which is good to know that I'm
getting my money's worth using it and
that it has these
functionalities again this is pretty
cool because I don't have to leave the
console to Google it I can see in the
results paint that the model has been
created and now I want to get a forecast
from it so I'm actually going to ask do
at AI to help me with that I'll prompt
in the chat how can I get a forecast in
SQL from my model duet AI gives me a
query so I'll copy it into my editor and
I want to change this a little bit
because I want my Horizon to be seven
and I actually want confidence level to
be95 hit
run and voila the query results pop up
here for the time series forecasting
model now I have a basic forecasting
model that I can query and share the
results with my team if I want to I can
go even further to visualize the results
in looker Studio but I'll save that for
another time I went from data ingestion
to understanding analysis and
forecasting in about 15 to 20 minutes
and the best part I didn't have to leave
the console once to look anything up
that's the power of duet
AI check out the links in the
description for the step-by-step
instructions and queries I use today and
to learn about using duet
[Music]
AI